at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
well hey everybody it's Wednesday once
again yeah and every time
every time before I push the button to
do the intro I'm like here comes the
baby hand because for some reason that
little baby hand like always like makes
me laugh every single time yeah today's
gonna be a true crime show and it is a
Florida case uh South Florida to be
specific which
um I can't remember who it was that
recommended it but I had actually never
heard about this case uh happened in
2007 so I guess that's probably why
because most of the cases that I'm
familiar with I guess are from
researching my faceless villain books
and that only goes up to 2000.
so I did start writing a volume four but
I only got up to 2002 on that before I
ran out of time and couldn't finish it
up but you know what I mean so yeah so I
actually had not uh heard about these
but yeah this is kind of interesting
because it kind of reminds me of you
remember that um the Dan Bell
uh one that we watch all the time that
real fancy mall like down in Miami
somewhere yeah yeah this I can't
remember what the name of it is I forgot
to it's not this it's not this one but
this is seems like a similar kind of
mall I don't think it's quite as fancy
as that one but it's like a pretty big
mall and it's in South Florida except in
2007 um so pretty shitty stuff happened
there so you know what I mean
Camp guy said it was on Unsolved
Mysteries or one of those other shows
yeah I think it was on um America's Most
Wanted a few times and uh as far as I
know to this day
um there's not a huge amount of
information about it um I went to the
Palm Beach County uh Police website
that's where they had most of the
information about it but
um it is still unsolved and they're not
really sure if the case is the two major
cases because there was you know more
there was more than two but the two
major ones they're not sure if they were
related or not and also there's kind of
um maybe a tie-in with a
now deceased serial killer although I'm
not really sure
I don't know it does kind of sound like
his ammo but not quite you know what I'm
saying we'll see so we'll get into that
and this I didn't want to get too much
into it because we did already did a
show about him a long time ago but you
know so there's that so let's kind of
just ease into the show got a couple of
shout outs
um xanada sent us
the next day so that's really cool so
thank you for that we're gonna be
reviewing that sometimes we still gotta
do breakfast club but you know what I
mean yeah that's we've waited so long to
do that one it's like oh I feel kind of
bad New York yeah but we get to King of
New York as well and also I think um I
thanked her on maybe Sunday's show but I
always like to thank people on the main
show just in case people don't watch the
other ones
um Celtic Angel 73 sent us a big box of
goodies uh including a Reagan oh I have
it right here still yeah a Reagan
Exorcist uh Funko Pop which is this is
super cool you guys
this face this is made me laugh like so
hard when I opened it like your little
eyes that are little restraints and
stuff like that so cute she's got vomit
all over her little nightgown yeah we
talk about the package in more detail I
think that was uh the last live stream
that we did yeah I think it was on
Sunday we talked about it yeah and um
she also sent she sent me a black
Christmas t-shirt and him a shirt of the
thing
um and also a gift card to buy some
stuff for Pookie in Beijing which is
much appreciated because they are out of
treats so I'll order some more treats
and she also sent us
um the entire series no not Dexter uh
bass Motel yeah the entire series of
Bates Motel so I've actually been
watching those uh off and on I watched
one episode last night and then I got
too tired but you know what I mean I
think I'm at the end I'm not sure if I'm
at the end of season one I'm sure I've
watched the whole entire first set of
discs like the whole the first box that
has I think like three discs in it I
think I've watched all of those so I
don't know I think that's 12 episodes
you know I don't know yeah yeah so I
think that's where I'm at I'm I'm right
at the part where
um I don't want to spoil anything but
where the teacher got killed
that's that's where I was so I think
that's episode 12.
Zach says I was at the big mall down in
Indianapolis last month for a date and
Lord it was so depressing over there
in Indianapolis
I mean some malls are still doing good
apparently I mean this mall that we're
talking about today despite all of the
horrible [__] that happened there back
in 2007 is apparently still open and
running I don't know if it's at full
capacity or not but it still has five
anchors like department stores it did
have six I think it had a Sears but as
far as I know like the Sears closed in
2018 like a lot of Sears did but it
still has Macy's it still has
Bloomingdale's it still hasn't Neiman
Marcus Nordstrom and Saks Fifth Avenue
and you know it still has like a Tesla
dealer and like a Louis Vuitton and all
that other kind of stuff in there so I
kind of feel like the ones that are
higher end are probably doing a lot
better because like I said if you if you
watch Dan Bell stuff I can't remember
the name of this [__] mall but it's
like a really really fancy like open air
one and it's one where like every single
store is like super designer everything
yeah 40 000 watches sixty thousand
dollar watch right they got professional
models walking around modeling clothing
and stuff walking around inside the the
ball itself because it's open Air Mall
and it's all Euro and everything's
mostly foreigners in there you can smoke
in there you know yeah which kind of
blew my mind yeah you smoke I mean it's
outdoor but the way they have it set up
yeah like I guess even if you get a
hurricane or something because you do I
guess it still doesn't get the stores
wet
if you're rich enough to shop in there
you can smoke
yeah only four people can't smoke
yeah you own this [__] come on smoke
all you want smoke up you can't tell
them what to do you can't tell what to
do because they just have all the money
yeah you could probably just have you
got cops oh I own whole [__] police
departments [__] out of here they
probably do yeah but yeah so I kind of
feel like this mall uh Jeffy art said I
still go to the Boca Town Center mall
quite a few times it's close to work
it's still pretty Lively yeah and I mean
the thing about it even some of the you
know um malls around here that aren't as
I mean there's a lot of dead malls
around here too but the one that balls
the one that we used to go to the
Altamonte Mall I mean that one was
pretty decent I mean it was almost at
full capacity like there there weren't
that many empty storefronts and it was
usually pretty crowded yeah but there
was a problem with it balls are supposed
to be high-end and that Mall's low end
well yeah they're selling used stuff in
there used video games and collectibles
well a lot of malls are going and the
anchors are [__] worn out and look
like [__] and the only reason was a
bunch of people in there is because it's
got a decent food court yeah it has a
massive food and it's near uh it's near
a low red district with the with a bunch
of
well there's like Apartments there's
like a um there's a really popular uh
Park like where there's like a lot of
like kind of nice restaurants and stuff
like that so a lot of people walk around
there that's where they do the fireworks
and stuff like that Dan will tell you
that the only two ends of the spectrum
still exist very high end or kind of
ghetto that's what exists because uh
high-end people go in there and buying
Cartier watches and [__] buying a
Lambo at the [__] mall
on the other end of the spectrum they
don't have ATM cards I guess or they
can't they don't do online shopping so
they're kind of
screwed they go in there and buy
overpriced over-the-counter [__]
you know I guess they're not an online
shopping because there's there are no
good deals in that mall if you look at
what their the prices of [__] with
that it's just junk you could get off of
Amazon for [__] twice the price with
Amazon selling it for
I mean the crazy thing about it is that
like I said we're kind of fascinated by
dead Mall videos yeah
um you know Dan Bell is like the best
known but there's like a bunch of other
channels that do it too and some of
those malls like there's literally like
two stores still open in this [__] and
it's like why do they even bother like I
don't how weird must it be to like work
in there uh well the two stores that are
open a lot of times are the are the
anchors
and people access the anchor from the
outside they don't even go through them
all so they just you know they come out
of the damn
uh parking lot and go right into the
anchor and then leave they never go into
the mall section
uh the sporting good stores are like
that I kind of feel like most and this
is like kind of a joke in the dead ball
Community but I kind of feel like this
the ball is dead but yet there's still
uh a GNC yeah and a Bed Bath and Beyond
yeah or not Bed Bath and Beyond uh Bath
and Body Works there's always a bath and
body works yeah it's because they're
selling their own products
they must not have much overhead yeah
and I think some of that [__] is just
still on the books because it's not
running in the red and it's just a big
machine GNC is just a big machine
but they say it's the last thing in the
mall to die it's a GNC it's like a
cockroach yeah pretty hard to destroy it
yeah yeah like I said
overheads because but yeah the mall that
we go to that's like it's actually right
across the parking lot from like the
movie theater that we used to go to like
it's all in one complex we go in there
to eat
yeah
to eat and then they had a little
collectible shop you could get well it
was an FYE yeah yeah they had used stuff
in there yeah used movies
and vinyl vinyl t-shirts Funko Pops yeah
the t-shirts were all new
but that was the only store that was
interesting in there the rest of it was
just they had a Barnes and Noble they
had a big Barnes and Noble that I like
to go to yeah that was nice I guess but
I think the reason why the Barnes and
Nobles did well is because they had a
Starbucks in it
most Burns I think all Barnes and Noble
have Starbucks and then um
if you looked at the move the movement
in the mall
most of it was the food court food court
was [__] packed it was always busy it
had good food in it I was sad that the
Indian place closed yeah but they had a
good like Mediterranean place I used to
go in there and get um get sandwiches
and stuff and like green salad that
clientele didn't know what Indian food
was they didn't they were gonna eat that
I didn't like hardly anybody was ever
eaten and I used to actually kind of
like go into Nature's Table too because
like they had some decent sandwiches but
that closed too but as I can't remember
what all was in there there's a there's
a Taco Bell there's a Mediterranean
place there's a Chinese place that's
where you usually eat at there's a sub
place or something there's a Japanese
place
there's one of those Philly cheesesteak
deals
yeah I think there's a Chick-fil-A I
can't remember what else if you're a Gen
X man you remember the malls the height
of the mall culture that was when we
were kids it was the height of the
although it was strong for a long long
time that's what you did when you were
yeah
at the mall you had to go to the mall if
you had to go shopping
and it just replaced a downtown shopping
district and it was air-conditioned it
was kind of like being a downtown but it
was air-conditioned in there
so you kind of had this weird sense of
being in something and out inside and
outside at the same time like something
out of Logan's Run
kind of an idealized [__]
Mercantile [__] experience with music
and food
but it's just from a guy bygone era you
know it was uh they were expensive
um they just can't survive in in the
time of you know in the era of [__]
Amazon online shopping well yeah I mean
nowadays you can get pretty much
whatever you want like yeah in a day or
two yeah Amazon has a much better
selection much better selection you have
to wait but it doesn't matter
if you don't like it you can just return
it and if you have Amazon Prime you
don't you only have to wait like a day
yeah
I'm sure [__] but yeah I was
never a big a big mall person I mean one
like um I was kind of like I I was I was
more a thrift store person
um but I would go to the mall on
occasion but it wasn't really my thing I
went to the mall in the day because they
had arcades in there like Aladdin's
Castle that was fun yeah somebody yeah
Camp guys talk about that yeah and
always usually across from Aladdin
Castle was the movie theaters so you go
to the movies and go to the arcades then
they would have like a Chick-fil-A in
there or and then they'd have something
like a licorice pizza or a Tower Records
or something or not Tower Records uh
what was the other one
we had a Camelot in ours yeah you could
buy records yeah records and tapes just
before CDs
ncds came out and then we had a record
town in there too in the 90s and I
worked there Harmony House that's what I
was thinking of not Tower Records
Harmony House had that
so uh you know
for a teenager there was a reason to go
and there was always girls there
well yeah it was more a social thing
yeah like I said I couldn't afford to
buy most [__] in there but actually the
mall where I grew up I grew up in
Daytona Beach
um Volusia Mall which is still there and
it's still doing okay I think I haven't
been there in a couple of years but they
have a books a million in there um which
I go and hang out because they also have
a coffee shop
um but for a while I don't know if it's
still in there but they had a really
good German restaurant called Mr
dunderbox it was like a German deli type
of thing it was tiny tiny tiny like
there was really only one or two tables
you couldn't really eat in there but
they had
um you could buy like all kind of like
meat and sauces and stuff like that but
then they made sandwiches and stuff like
that too and uh then they also had like
hot food but yeah it was like really
really good I don't know if it's in
there though because I I haven't been
there in like a really long time but I
used to work there like I said I worked
at record town which I think got taken
over and then became FYE I think I
remember my whole life even as a kid
the [__] clothes the clothing
selection that balls sucked ass it did
it was the clothes that your that your
parents wanted you to [__] wear this
[__] [__] suck the only thing that
you might be halfway cool is that in the
record stores you could get uh uh
[__] like bands t-shirts they had bad
t-shirts and posters I think you could
get those in other places too but they
mostly [__] sucked I remember [__]
looking through there and go like man
where the [__] does where's Billy Idol
[__] buy at his clothes and I was
like where the [__] you know where in
the mall did they do like the punk rock
I didn't know yeah then I went back yeah
I remember when I got there holding
their clothes in there yeah when I got a
little bit older I [__] looked at
[__] been at Billy Idol and he's
wearing a [__] wetsuit top with the
arms cut off of it like that's a [__]
wetsuit
well you know back in the day you had to
make your own yeah
yeah
leather pads
and [__] boots I mean there were
stores if you had a big if you were in a
big city but yeah well and the thing
about this I know this is crazy and I
don't think it's there anymore but when
I was growing up
in Daytona Beach of all places you
wouldn't think it would have something
like this because it's kind of you know
rednecky but we used to have this place
and it was in like the worst
neighborhood too it was like right along
where all the prostitutes and crackheads
were but it was called Judy's Jazzy
Boutique and it was run by this
hilarious like profane old lady and her
daughter his name was Judy
and they sold they had like a section in
the back that was like all sex toys and
porn but then in the front they had
pretty much every kind of like punk rock
clothes they had wigs they had stripper
clothes they had all kind of like cool
ass boots
um they had used stuff they had new
stuff they had hippie clothes they had
like pretty much anything you could
think of that was like alternative they
had all of that [__] that's where um Jen
from the Jenna torture is used to every
time she was in town she used to go
there and Shop so I would always like
save up and go and hang out
there because the the two women that ran
it were like super funny but um they
didn't even bother I don't know if they
were you know independently wealthy or
something like that but sometimes they
didn't even bother opening the store
like sometimes you would go and you'd
think that it would be an open and then
they would just like not be there and
then sometimes they'd come rolling in
like it at 5 30 and they're like oh yeah
whatever we were just yeah I wasn't busy
all the time no it probably wasn't but
they had like a lot of really cool [__]
in there so I got a lot of stuff in
there but I'm sure it's gone now because
that woman I'm sure is long passed away
because she was old as [__] when I was
going there back in the old days
Zach says uh you'll like this I saw a
video on fashion trends that are
supposed to be popular this year and one
was like an elegant goth look guess
that's been a lot of runways lately yeah
I kind of feel like every few years we
kind of get popular again like with the
fashion designers we thought that if
something was going to happen because of
you know the Netflix series Wednesday
and I was like oh that means that like
goth is going to come back around again
it did kind of yeah yeah there's a
there's a whole bunch of Wednesday Adams
inspired fashion and uh yeah yeah
non-goth girls are trying to get that
look
you know so it's like now I feel like I
can't wear my little dress with the
white collar anymore because everyone
will think I'm trying to be Wednesday
and I'm like no I just I guess there's
millions millions of different
interpretations of that dress that's
true there's a lot of those
I'm just I don't know some of them don't
have backs on them there's all kinds of
stuff that you can yeah so number two
peas some of them are one piece there's
a lot of stuff that looks kind of like a
Wednesday Adams type dress
yeah Zach said oh yeah it actually was
because of Wednesday the lady said yeah
that's what I thought we we thought that
when we were watching the show every
time a movie or something comes out it's
real popular yeah everybody's like oh
yeah they remember that we exist and
we're like it'll last for about two
three years
and then we'll be lame again now it'll
just be forgotten yeah
talking about Spencer's yeah I think the
mall in Daytona still has a Spencers I
don't I don't know if the ultimate
spring one does uh Camp guy said I
always hit the bookstores One Mall had
both a Walden books and a b Dalton yeah
the one that where I grew up had both of
those they were small but I used to go
in there too but the one it has now it
has the big books a million like it's
kind of like an anchor
it was there last time I went there but
it's been like a year or two I guess but
uh yeah somebody he also said Magic Pan
crepe restaurant
huh never heard of it I've heard of it
but I don't think we have any around
here I would totally eat there though
because I [__] love Crepes man and I
never I used to make them like every now
and then but I haven't made any for a
really long time Danny Rowling also said
eBay is just as good as Amazon yeah
sometimes I can find really good [__] on
eBay I just I usually forget to look to
be honest with you
delivery isn't as fast
yeah that's true I kind of feel like
Amazon just kind of like took over the
whole [__] world well just because
they have warehouses everywhere yeah
they got their own delivery vehicles and
[__] and you can just like you know get
stuff immediately and then I also said
Suncoast video was the [__] in the mall
yeah I remember that I remember that
being really cool
but yeah it's you know
it's just surprising that
as many of them are dying out I guess
there are still a lot that are doing
okay it depends on the location yeah
location is everything and like I said
it's it's the two ends of the spectrum
it's in a good location but it's very
low rent
or it's in a good location and it's
[__] way out of your price range
right you know yeah I can't afford it go
down here and get another one yeah go
down there and get a [__] 15 espresso
you know our 20 [__] cup of coffee
that's priced to keep all the riffraff
out that better be some good [__]
coffee that's what I'm just saying I
better that that better be orgasmically
good yeah
and if you look at videos of the places
we're talking about here in Miami it's
just foreigners
Americans don't go to that
foreigners that live here the Dan Bell
one I mean the one that I can't the one
that I can't remember that's what I said
yeah the one on my the one in Miami yeah
one in Miami here not the one that we're
talking about today
no the one on Dan Bell Americans don't
go in there that's foreigners
or the our [__] asses don't have no
money
yeah people from Saudi and [__] [__]
real Rich Europeans but I think it's
mostly middle easterners
Zach said my theater professor in
college said she used to work at
Spencer's Gifts I always wanted to ask
her if she sold the penis candles and
lava lamps well it's funny because when
I was growing up like Spencer's you know
that's where he went to get like you
said lava lamps and black light posters
and [__] like that they didn't have sex
toys until later
they don't have like real hardcore sex
toys but they have yeah they have like
vibrators and you know dildos and stuff
like that which they didn't have that
when I was growing up that was like a
later Edition actually the back of the
one in uh Daytona last time I was in
there it was all like Playboy stuff you
know what I mean like there's all the
Branded Playboy stuff like toys and
pillows and that's all gone now I think
I don't think there is a Playboy brand
you think anyone needs gone I think you
think anyone used the candles as dildos
oh I'm sure
you know somebody stuck that up their
ass and had to go to the ER and get it
removed
man there was something somebody
I think that was on Gore Gallery a long
time ago if you guys probably don't
remember Gore Gallery but there's a
whole section of x-rays from the
hospital of things that people put put
up their ass yeah when it was like a
shampoo bottle
yeah uh like a [__] big ass [__]
toy truck
it's [__] crazy yeah that's like not
even shaped like it would go and you're
not I'm not really sure like I could see
something like like you said like a
shampoo bottle or something which at
least is approximate
kind of a shape of a butt yeah look like
it looked like a like a
like a semi truck you know what I mean
we could go along
somebody wanted all those sharp angles I
guess he's driving the truck
some kinky ass Foods
[Laughter]
I wonder if I always wanted to know like
what the although they may have been a
story behind it you know maybe oh I'm
sure there was somebody shoved the
[__] shoved it up his ass like yeah
maybe maybe it wasn't consensual you
don't know it was just that's just I'm
just x-rated I'm just curious to know
what the story was that he told the
people at the hospital when he got there
like he slipped and fell yeah I just
fell on it I fell and it went up my head
I was in the shower and I fell
and my kid had this toy truck and he
left it like standing right up like that
like he'll have this big elaborate I was
walking okay and my toe hit the end of
the carpet and I tripped and I fell yeah
and landed on it yeah and it went shoot
yeah like right up you know because his
butt was greasy it happens all the time
sure I I could totally do that my sister
used to um she used to do billing for a
GI clinic so yeah she had all kind of
fun stories about it
putting stuff up their butts and
swallowing weird [__] and everything
like that yeah she used to tell me I'm
um Danny Rowling said how many people
were murdered in this case
um three it was two women and one little
girl
so uh yeah and like I said it was
they're not really sure if the two main
ones are related but we'll get into that
in a little bit uh Jeff yard said there
was a comic store in a mall near my
childhood home that used to sell
Godzilla action figures from Bandai all
from Japan oh yeah I still have my
collection well didn't you say that you
there was a store near where you grew up
in California yeah it was called uh
Pinocchio's and they sold all that bad
guy stuff and stuff from bullmark at the
other company yeah yeah yeah the [__]
it's cool man [__] um I had a damn
jumbo machinder which is you know
remember the big old mazingas and
[__] dragons and [__] the Shogun
Sheldon Warriors put out well that was
those were knockoffs basically
um of the ones at the end Japan the ones
that had in Japan they were [__] even
better
but I had a Japanese one it was cabaler
V and [__] remember when I turned
about 16 I threw that [__] away
that day's worth four grand now
four grand I just threw it away so there
weren't very many of them that came in
the United States
and most of the ones that came to the
United States went through that [__]
that [__] shop out there I think it
was Whittier California
Alicia Marie said I lived in Boca at the
time I have a crazy story I moved to
Florida in August 2007. oh that's when
the first incident happened by the way
uh by December I went home from
Christmas break no idea about the
murders yeah like the main with the the
first murder happened in August and the
second one happened like right in
December like right before Christmas
time and there were a couple of other
incidents too where the people weren't
killed but they were kind of similar and
they thought that they were maybe
related
but yeah so this happened in Boca Raton
which is if you don't know is um about
20 miles north of Fort Lauderdale so
it's you know in the larger like Miami
South Florida area way far from here way
far from here yeah I I do kind of feel
like people
um but when you say they're that you're
from Florida
um sometimes people don't realize how
large Florida is like Miami I've been
there a couple of times but it's far I
mean it's probably from here
a four or five hour drive yeah I think
Florida is bigger than a lot of European
countries I think Florida and Italy are
about the same size now that I now that
I'm thinking in Texas so far America if
I recall is twice the size of Germany
I think that's about right
yeah I mean well the thing about Italy
the thing about Italy is that it's it's
kind of similar in size because it's
long and narrow kind of like Florida is
and I think it's very very similar in
size so that's what so if you're
European like if it's about the same
sizes yeah Florida one a couple years
back it's probably better now because uh
the index has gone up
we were had a GDP similar to the
Netherlands
so Florida could be an independent
country and survive
Alicia said so she gets uh she went home
for Christmas break no idea about the
murders I get back to Boca and hear my
upstairs neighbor who's so creepy
fighting with his girlfriend she's
screaming you killed her it was so scary
I called my mom and told her I think he
killed somebody I had absolutely no idea
that it happened so I didn't think to
call him in I found out years later holy
[__]
I wonder if that's the game because they
haven't they never they haven't caught
the people that did it so
you know what I mean I might have just
had a crazy girlfriend that was accusing
who killed somebody though too well yeah
that's what I mean you never know I mean
you don't know the context of it but
still I mean if you heard somebody
arguing upstairs and if you like if your
upstairs neighbor was legit creepy and
like you heard somebody saying you
killed I'm like I would probably call
that in just in case you know what I
mean you never know like I said it might
be nothing
but it might be something
the cops wouldn't be able to do anything
about it I know that's true but it would
it would probably just make you feel
better that you did something and that
motherfucker's watching you you read me
out yeah
yeah they come down and kill you yeah
yeah Jesus Christ
uh Camp guy said I believe it was
someone from a nearby less affluent
neighborhood a really sharp well-spoken
Street sharper type criminal yeah they
kind of think that maybe I mean they
have some suspects but
um they haven't really caught anybody
so all right so this mall in Boca Raton
like I said is kind of like I guess it's
sort of an upscale mall it's not as
upscale as the one in the Dan Bell video
but I think it's approximating those and
like I said it seemed pretty like it
still has all its [__] together it still
has almost all of its anchors and has
like it has like a Tesla dealer it has
like um you know a lot of uh designer
stores in there and [__] like that and
is actually the largest
enclosed shopping mall in Palm Beach
County and the third largest in South
Florida so it's kind of big it's a big
deal
however back in 2007
um they started having some issues like
with crime thank you very much Bryce
I've never heard of these murders this
looks like a good episode I had actually
never heard of them either even though
I've lived in Florida pretty much my
entire life
um like I said South Florida is kind of
far away but
these ones well I don't know I don't
know we just never heard of them and I
guess it because it was more recent even
though 2007 was a long time ago to me it
seems recent because it seemed like just
the other day that it was 2007. but um
you know I'm more familiar like I said
with ones that are older
um all right so
what happened in 2007
the first incident uh you know that they
know of and this was like one of the
major incidents
uh there was a woman who was she was 52
years old now she was originally from
Brooklyn but she had moved to Florida at
some time in the past she had two kids
who were grown
um and she was she 52 years old did I
say that her name was Randy gorenberg
now on March 23rd 2007
she went to the mall and this was like
broad daylight it was a night or nothing
like that it was like the afternoon
she goes into the mall and she buys they
know what she bought um she bought a
pair of shorts and she bought a John
Legend CD
now
they saw they they saw her on
surveillance cameras like in the parking
lot like leaving the mall and like going
out into the parking lot
and then later on
um they found her uh
black SUV which was new like it was a
Mercedes SUV abandoned in a Home Depot
parking lot
so at this point when they looked at the
surveillance footage and they got some
witness statements
about a half hour after she was seen
leaving the mall on the surveillance
footage
at least one witness possibly multiple
watched her she was in the passenger
seat of her SUV
and someone else like some dude was
driving it
and he basically just shot her twice in
the head
when she was in the passenger seat and
just pushed her out the SUV and like I
said this is the middle of the day
and he just like pushed her out the car
in um Governor Lawton child's Memorial
Park which is in Delray Beach and that's
where they found her body like a little
while later because a bunch of witnesses
like called in and said holy [__] we
think somebody just
shot a woman and like just pushed her
out her car
now the only really leads they had about
it was that they think that there was
another car I don't know
um this was just from the Palm Beach
County like Police website but they said
a white Chrysler might have been
involved so I don't know if they saw the
white Chrysler like on the surveillance
footage from the mall parking lot like
maybe stalking her or something like
that not really sure
but her abandoned SUV that they found
they got a bunch of DNA samples out of
the car
um and that they were kind of hoping
that they would be able to match it to
somebody obviously that's why they
collected it but they have so far not
found any matches
interestingly and I'm not really sure
why this is like I said there's not a
huge amount of information about this
case
um you know it was kind of just
repeating a lot of the same stuff and
the Palm Beach County Police website
seemed to have the most stuff about it
but they didn't really go into detail on
a lot of things that I kind of wish they
would
but they said a lot of the genetic
material that they found in the car
they matched it they were trying to
match it to
friends of Randy gorenberg's son Daniel
so I was thinking that their earlier or
their early theory was that maybe
allegedly I don't know if this is just
me speculating here but maybe they
thought that her son who I'm presuming
was grown like maybe in his 20s or
whatever because she was 52.
that maybe he like hung out with some
sketchy ass people and they were
thinking that maybe he had set her up I
don't know why they would think that but
um but they did test a bunch of his
friends like to see if that but it
didn't match any of them
now they also tested
her husband Stuart
so I don't know like I said I don't know
what her husband or son I don't know if
they were suspicious in other ways and
that's why I mean I know that they
usually have to like eliminate family
members and stuff like that first but
you know they didn't really give a lot
of uh specifics on that there was some
kind of Reason yeah they're that's what
I'm saying there must have been a reason
but I guess because they didn't find
anything they didn't really go too much
into it far away was the SUV from the
body
um it couldn't have well I don't know
actually I think the park is only a
couple of miles from them all
okay like basically just dumped her out
in a park and then drove the SUV
somewhere and left it like in a Home
Depot parking lot
so they abducted her from the mall or
from the mall Park from the mall parking
lot yeah and like I said it was the
middle of the day no no shot her in the
car it took her somewhere and shot her
took her well they think what might have
happened because this is what happened
in some of the later cases even though
they don't know if this is related but
they think that it might have been they
might have driven made her drive to like
a ATM or something like that and like
take money out and then shot her and
dumped her out there was no records of
an ATM withdrawal the in her case I
don't think so but I think because
they're that's kind of what happened in
some of the later cases but like I said
I'm not really sure if these two are
related something happened they were
going to abduct her and steal money or
steal the vehicle and they had to shoot
her
it's pretty freaky that this I mean this
wasn't even at night like I said this
was like the middle of the [__]
afternoon you just go in the mall it's
actually pretty common I know it is but
like that like I said that's like really
I don't want to say ballsy because that
sounds like I'm admiring but I was like
it's you know well they're desperate
I guess they have to get somebody first
they have to get some a person or a car
and the best time is in during store
hours you know when or you know during
working hours where people are running
around yeah and you guess you can get
kind of lost in the crowd
but uh just like you know when they
abduct kids or women it's from malls
it's it's during store hours yeah a lot
of people have been abducted from balls
over the years I don't think it's as bad
as it was because cameras
came later on but I've never been to 80s
that's where a lot of serial killers
abducted women from malls Christopher
Wilder did that [__] yeah I remember
that guy did we do a show about that guy
I don't know he took him to motels
somebody to keep them for a few days and
then kill him he was they called him the
beauty queen killer yeah he was the one
that would always approach and say hey
I'm a photographer right yeah exactly
like in mall parking lots or inside the
mall too yeah do that as well I don't
remember if we did a show about
Christopher Wilder I think we did but
he's well he's kind of um
he's not originally American I think he
was Australian originally but he moved
here when he was younger and I remember
I always remember him because one he was
on there was a show about him and
unsolved Mission he's dead now like they
shot him in a police shootout but um
like when he tried to evade police
but they thought that maybe he might
have been responsible for those real
famous
um Australia like the Wanda Beach
Burgers which we did do a show about
um I don't know if if that's the but he
is one of the um killers that they kind
of Bandy about I remember correctly he
would take them to hotels or motels
yeah I don't really remember all the
details but he's he's the main one I
know there's been more than one like you
know that abduct people from from all
parking lots but um like he's the one
that I mainly remember because I
remember seeing like all those shows
about him yeah cameras put the kibosh on
that though well the weird thing about
it is though this happened in 2007 it
was the middle of the day there were
cameras because she they caught her on
surveillance cameras like going to her
car or whatever so they knew what time
she left the mall but they still didn't
could see any who did it yeah they still
couldn't see anybody as far as I know
they didn't even really get nobody got a
good look at the person
so um so yeah so for a while they were
investigating
um her husband Stuart as well
um now Stuart
filed a lawsuit against the mall
presumably because it's like you know
how could this happen and stuff which
you know that's understandable I guess
but after a while he stopped cooperating
with the police department for whatever
reason and
um at least at the time they said he was
never eliminated as a suspect
okay so take that as you will not really
entirely sure about that
um like I said they also looked into
leads having to do with her son Daniel
who I presume like hung out with sketchy
[__] otherwise why would they
bother with it but more money oh thank
you very much Aaron have a drink on me
Jenny looking great as usual thank you
very much that'll buy several drinks
yeah
thank you very much I appreciate
who's that buddy we all yeah well every
I like money yeah
you like money oh yeah I like money too
I can't believe you like mine
chances
yeah um Zach says I often wonder in
cases like this how much is it just
someone having a total psychotic episode
or a real bad drug trip who doesn't even
know what they're doing
um
maybe I probably not as many as you
might think I don't know maybe it is
more than I think
some people are just like [__]
it's just more some dudes just [__]
their nuts and they're kind of semi
they're either kind of semi-suicidal
they don't care if they get caught or
not maybe the part of them wants to get
caught so they'll do something real
daring like this in front of everybody
other ones are just they think they're
bulletproof no one will ever see me
that's how slick I am so just kind of
delusional but it works I feel like a
lot of cereal yeah I like that look at
it this way
let's say you put your bicycle up on
your front porch in the middle of the
day you come out 20 minutes later and
it's [__] gone you go you go what
kind of idiot would steal a [__] my
bicycle throughout the front porch in
the middle of the day couldn't have been
that much of it he's gone he's got your
bicycle yeah and nobody saw you're not
gonna get it back you're not gonna get
it back are you speaking of Molly
somebody stole my bicycle from the mall
because I rode my bike to the mall one
time and then I came out a couple hours
later and someone had taken it but even
though it was locked up I locked it on
the bike rack was it an expensive one no
but I was still not but then I had to
walk home and it was far
I was mad somebody with a car and a pair
of bolt cutters they jumped out [__]
cut a boat I was like who the [__] wants
my shitty bike suit in the back seat and
left that's one that's really one of the
only good things about being broke all
the time is like nobody wants my [__]
that's why I was like I'm not worried
about my car or anything like that it's
like steal it yeah her car looks like
[__]
I'm like it's insured buy me a new one
nobody wants that [__] wanted to buy her
another one man but we got to get her
credit cards paid off first yeah I know
yeah
um Alicia Marie says the most common
place to kidnap is the grocery store
I believe it I believe it probably more
commentable because probably more common
nowadays than malls because you know
everybody got to go to the grocery store
unless you get unless you get hello
fresh or something you know what I mean
yeah so I I think some people have been
kidnapped from like the Walmart parking
lots too well because the thing about it
is like those super Walmarts have those
massive massive parking lots and like
way in the back even like the one in
Daytona which is on Williamson it had
like a huge huge huge parking lot and
like the way in the back was like dark
there wasn't I mean there was some
lights but not that many and like
sometimes people would go like [__]
Camp back there like in their uh you
know campers and yeah crap like that so
you're always finding like bottles of
pee and [__] like that yeah I don't
think that stuff is being recorded I
think it's just security guards
supposedly watching the cameras except
they're probably just like looking out
pouring and jerking it while they're
supposed to they don't pay those guys
very much and they're like you know
that's what I mean it's like yeah it's
beyond my pay grade
it might record it might record it but
then like they'll probably keep it for a
couple days and then they just recorded
over it
yeah I'm just thinking that like yeah
why would you keep it because it's
probably like hours and hours of like
[__] all happening yeah right
so um so for a couple of years nothing
ever really happened with this case but
a few years later in 2011
uh the authorities actually came out and
they said that they had a person of
interest in the case now this guy was a
dude named Michelle Barrera and uh as
far as I know he is still a fugitive
from Justice
he's actually
um associated with the MS-13 gang in
South Florida
um he was also prior to this incident uh
he was also wanted for several other
crimes uh he has a very long list
including bank robbery attempted murder
of a law enforcement officer uh there
was like a police shootout during a high
speed chase and [__] like that uh he was
actually on
America's Most Wanted like three times
they're looking for his ass he's gone
he's back to South America but um well
yeah he's from uh I think he's from El
Salvador yeah he's back inside
originally that's where he is
um what how he came to the attention of
police I guess was that um a guy in
prison like an inmate told the cops that
he had heard like some chatter inside
about a gang
um taking responsibility for the murder
and that Michelle Barrera had been the
shooter so I'm not really sure if it was
even a robbery or if it was like some
kind of initiation thing like allegedly
they don't know if this guy did it or
not
now they did say that they um the
surveillance footage that they had from
the mall from when she was abducted her
car had been um being followed by
another car whose description looked
like
a car that was owned by one of
Michelle's relatives that he drove
sometimes so that's kind of like why
they why he came to their attention so
the MS-13 gang I had never heard of this
gang but um I guess they're kind of like
they are based in Los Angeles but I
guess they have chapters everywhere like
like a gang does and like I said it was
originally set up to protect uh
immigrants from El Salvador like from
other gangs but then like it turned into
its own gang
eventually
um so yeah and it's they're they're
supposedly like really bad [__]
and so this guy Michelle Barrera is
still
a fugitive like you said he's probably
out of the country because this was a
long time ago like 2011 they came out
and announced where he was but I think
that like the last time he was on
America's Most Wanted was maybe back in
2008 like a year after this happened so
yeah he's back he's backing us over
either that or he's been like mowed down
at some point like you can find his body
though
I don't know he's back in El Salvador
they never find him there then he's not
wanted there
I'm imagine I mean he might he very well
might be I don't really know
yeah unless he's got other charges down
there yeah but he's somewhere in South
America where he can hide
Zach said that reminds me of when me and
my dad went shopping when I was a kid
and we were almost done someone stole
our cart so we had to go back and get
everything all over again
that's like somebody too lazy to shop
hey that looks good I'm just sick of
yours
ah okay okay said someone took my
grocery cart one time and I found it two
aisles over with stuff inside I didn't
select that's so weird to me it's like I
can see
stealing it well I mean I could see
stealing it like after you've already
paid for all of it yeah but if you're
just like walking around to the store
and you haven't paid for it yet why the
[__] would somebody do these little kids
little kids right yeah the carton
running with yay I got it
I got all the cereals yeah and they
throw it and run go get another one oh
my God
uh but yeah
so um as I said this murder is still not
solved this poor yeah what's the matter
Pope yeah this poor woman just [__]
at the mall buying a pair of shorts and
then suddenly she gets [__] shot in
the head and pushed out her own [__]
car which you know that's sucky
so that happened in March of 2007.
now in August of the same year
there was um a woman unnamed because you
know she's still alive thankfully but um
she was kind of a younger woman and she
had her two-year-old son with her
and they were abducted from the same
parking lot the Boca Raton uh Town
Center I don't know what the [__]
official name of this mall is like the
Wikipedia page called it the Town Center
at Boca Raton but they said it also is
called Boca Town Center Town Center mall
or just Town Center so I'm like okay
make up your [__] mind I guess it's
called Town Center at Boca Raton it's
the official name but whatever
so so yeah so this woman and her
two-year-old were
um abducted from the same parking lot
now they were forced at gunpoint to go
to an ATM and they and she had to
withdraw 600
now what the guy did was he
he tied them up like with zip ties
and put duct tape over their mouths and
their wrists I think and then he had
these goggles that were like blacked out
yeah and he put them on there too and
that's like I said that's kind of a
detail that'll come up later because I
happen to get in like in the later
murder case but these two thankfully
survived like the guy just took them to
the ATM like with all the [__] on their
face and they took out 600 and gave it
to him and he just like took him back to
the mall parking lot and just dropped
them off so they actually you know
obviously went right to the cops and
were like what the [__] but they didn't
really see the dude you know what I mean
like all that well he took them in his
vehicle or their vehicle
um I think theirs and then he took him
back and then he got jumped out of the
vehicle left him in there I guess I'm
not real clear on like whose vehicle it
was no description of the guy
there what you know what
um this guy in particular they do have
there is a sketch of him if you go to if
you Google like Boca Town Center murders
um there's really only one sketch he
looks like
this catch kind of reminds me a little
bit and it's gonna sound funny but he
kind of reminds me a little bit of
Steven Seagal well but Steven Seagal but
also kind of like with a weird because
he had like a kind of a I remember he
had like a weird gilligany type hat on
right kind of It kind of looked like
that but he looked like maybe a white
guy or maybe a Hispanic guy it was kind
of hard to tell
but um but yeah but there is a and even
Segal folks yeah Steven Seagal did it
with probably like a booty here it
wasn't fat enough she wasn't fat enough
to be Steven Seagal he went on a diet I
guess he hit that booty cap on to make
it look more like like a seal Special
Operation hi guys I mean they said the
guy had like a hat and sunglasses so
they didn't really get a good look at
his face but they so in the sketch like
he has like a hat and sunglasses on so
it's hard to tell what he looks like
now a few days after this incident
there was a 19 year old woman who thank
you very much Jeffy art says my hero
I'll give it to Seagal Oscar Perez says
maybe a white guy maybe a Hispanic guy
relatable
it's all about to say well I mean
whoever drew the guy was just it seemed
like they were kind of trying to hedge
their bets you know Hispanic is the new
white now
you said quite quite
like HW yeah into H yeah now a few days
after that this 19 year old woman now
she wasn't actually at the mall she was
a couple miles away at Mizner Park
um I think it was that's about four
miles away and the same thing happened
to her like she got robbed at gunpoint
also and the guy took her to an ATM
um but she gave him 200 and and he let
her go
so those were two more incidents like I
said they don't know if those are
related to the Randy gorenberg murder
but
then
a few weeks before Christmas of 2007 it
was actually December 12th
one of the security guards at the Boca
Raton Town Center Mall
saw a Chrysler Aspen like a 2007 a black
one
in the parking lot with the engine
running it was actually parked um near
the Sears which is gone now it's like I
said I think it closed in 2018.
now he didn't really like approach the
car or anything like that he just saw
the car and it was the engine was
running and it didn't look like anybody
was in it so he was like well that's
weird so he called the police report he
didn't call 9-1-1 but he just called
like the non-emergency line or whatever
and said can you like have a cop come
out here and like check it out
so police came out and found inside the
vehicle a 47 year old woman named Nancy
bocici bocikio I think is how you
pronounce her last name
and her seven-year-old daughter Joey
uh both of them were tied up and shot
damn they were both dead
so the cops obviously uh you know combed
through there and got like a bunch of
DNA and everything like that
and then they were trying to figure out
like you know they went back through uh
you know the surveillance footage and
everything like that to kind of figure
out what had happened so what ended up
happening with Nancy and Joey they have
surveillance footage of them going into
the mall like between the Sears on the
Neiman Marcus
um on the afternoon of Wednesday and
December 12 2007. it was about 2 19 p.m
that's when they were on the camera
they were in the mall for almost an hour
um they came out the same doors at about
11 minutes past 3 P.M
and at that point I guess they didn't
see what happened to them but they're
presuming that at this point they were
abducted from the parking lot someplace
where the cameras maybe couldn't see
them and then they were taken to a
nearby ATM where they were forced to
withdraw five hundred dollars there is a
record of that now there was a 9-1-1
call made from Nancy's cell phone
um the Palm Beach County Sheriff's
Office got it but the call was
disconnected before they could answer it
so the operator actually tried to call
the phone back but no one answered
so maybe that's why she got shot
um I well yeah I'm not really no maybe
he saw her on with that phone tried to
call yeah shot her maybe so
but the thing about it is that this
seemed to take some time because just
like in the
prior case where the woman and her son
were abducted
um Nancy and Joey were also bound
with um zip ties duct tape and the
goggles so they both had that right it's
the same guy yeah that well obviously
that's like the same dude now
um so they were must have been in the
car for like a while because they said
their hands and feet were tied
um and then they also like had stuff
like around their neck too so like they
couldn't move as much
now when they found the bodies Nancy's
um the bindings on her wrists were
broken now I saw another source like I
said there's not a huge amount of
information about these cases but I saw
another source that said her wrists were
broken and I said I don't think that's
the case because the information that I
got came right from like the Palm Beach
County Police Department thing and I
think that whoever wrote this other
thing was using that but misunderstood
okay they said that the the bindings
around her wrists were broken her actual
wrists weren't broken as far as I know
so they don't actually know
if
she was trying to break the bonds and
that's why there's or maybe the person
like the killer did it or something like
that they're not really any sure they're
not really sure it's weird that he uh
committed
two of these things
he let what was it the first couple go
it was a mom and her and her little son
he was the second second couple he
killed yeah he got a total of 1100 bucks
for this didn't he yeah 605 yeah
and maybe they don't know if he was the
same guy that did the one in Mizner Park
right like that 19 year old girl that he
let go that was 200 he let her go yeah
did 200. that wasn't at the mall that
was a couple miles away though he's
awful desperate he's not making much
money
and then he's gotta he's gotta lay money
out for the damn goggles and the zip
ties that's what I mean this seems
really weird it seems really weird yeah
to go to that much effort for just like
a robbery and like you said like a small
amount of money
when
he's just a real novice I guess
I mean you could do a note job in a bank
and have a much greater
catch and a better
and a better chance of success doing a
no job and you don't have to kill
anybody and if you get caught doing a
note job you don't even have a gun on
you it's not armed robbery see that's
what I was doing that's what I would do
yeah and it ends up the feds might pick
it up so you do fed time nice and sweet
in the federal penitentially some state
so there's just a bunch of different
ways to steal money to where the you can
get more
for Less risk and then you end up in a
better offender profile so you can end
up in a sweeter prison
it just doesn't make any sense he
doesn't know what he's doing he's just
some dude he's it's Steven Seagal it's
Steven seagull that's who it is
allegedly go that's why he's in Russia
allegedly
I don't know why I don't know why the
sketch reminded because I mean I saw the
sketch a couple hours ago so it could be
that I'm just kind of conflating but for
some reason like that was the first
impression that I got yeah I saw the
SketchUp I think I think what happened
is she was getting away she was gonna
get out he he thought she had he saw her
using a phone and trying or you know he
saw her using the phone or she had
busted her arrested he panics and [__]
shoots them both
were there any more after this
not that I know I didn't have a belly
for it he's like this ain't worth it he
stopped doing it
Camp guy said he knows lots of single
women go to malls and you know affluent
yeah I guess so you're not gonna get
anything you're not gonna get anything
out of him though
well the weird thing about the job you
can get 20 grand the thing about forcing
people to go to ATMs it's like you can
only take so much out of an ATM every
day you know if there's a limit yeah
so and you know you're not he's not
stealing enough money to live on
so why is he bothering with this
like I said you could do a no job
probably get 20 grand
you know that's what the cashiers might
have they might have around that
I mean the other thing if I was going to
turn to a life of crime I would probably
do something like yeah you want to go to
where you're you're you're going to get
a you just want one big score big score
less chance of getting caught and if you
do get caught
you're gonna do sweet time for it
you can do a lot better yeah I think the
way the best way to go about it like I
said I'm not gonna do this but I'm just
saying if I was going to would be like
you said like don't have any weapons on
you to threaten anybody anything like
that you could just like you know just
go in there because they have to give
you the money yeah yeah he it's a guy's
working the system they have to give you
the money yeah and uh well because they
don't want anybody to get killed right I
mean yeah and then you know he's
got a bit you know there are guys who at
least uh back in the 80s and 90s that
they were professional guys
um from middle class backgrounds doing
this some of them educated
and hit hit 40 or 50 bags
some of sometimes they'd hit a back
three or four times
you know over a period of years they'd
go back to a bank that they already did
they were living in living totally
normal lives and the wives never knew
that it was a bank robber any dudes were
doing it in their 60s and 70s
I remember hearing remember that guy
anyway leave on a bicycle
yeah yeah because there's nothing yeah
there's like it's not suspicious if you
just see like an old dude riding a bike
yeah yeah
that's yeah I mean sometimes like I said
I'm not a big fan of like obviously
people that come in and like you know
shoot people and [__] like that but it's
like I almost kind of have for a Big
Heist type crimes yeah like I said I
read a book about
um and I still want to do a show about
it but it never wins in the poll
um about the Antwerp uh Diamond Heist
like those got that gang that did that
and I don't think they ever got caught
and they got like a [__] ton of funny
and um but the way that they went about
it was just like so meticulous and like
they thought of everything I was like
you are I'm like almost that's kind of
awesome well they were organized
criminals and they didn't hurt anybody
they didn't hurt anybody yeah they you
know they stole money it's it's illegal
you know right I know that but it's just
like they uh I'm always kind of like
they would just organized criminals they
had an inside information they knew
where it was going to be and they've got
a plan together and to get it but um you
know anytime anytime you're using
violence with any of these kind of
crimes where you're trying to steal
like for instance
you say I don't want to do a no job I'm
going to do it I want to do a [__]
takeover robbery me and all my friends
are gonna run into this Bank we're gonna
have assault rifles and masks to be just
like out of the movie Heat
and we're gonna shoot the [__]
ceiling up and intimidate everybody
we're gonna get as much money as we can
we're trying to get them to open the
vaults and then we'll run out of there
that's basically what [__] old animal
and the other guy did for the [__]
South Hollywood shooting yeah we did do
a show yeah
as soon as they s the feds see you Robin
Banks the [__] assault rifles and
body armors masks and [__] you go right
to the top of the list there you're like
oh these [__] are dangerous
they're gonna kill somebody yeah sooner
or later and they're going to move you
to the top of the list they're going to
be forgetting all about these damn get
dude these old men doing no jobs
well who who stole more money over time
those dudes with no jobs yeah you know
because they just
yeah they're trying to catch them
they're just not but they're not real
high priority because they're at real
low risk and there's lots of those
you know there's lots of guys doing and
the thing about it I just can't be sad
about people stealing money from Banks
they have plenty
you know what I mean
but you know what I mean but yeah but
they're insured that yeah that's what I
mean it's like oh they're not going to
be homeless or anything like that don't
worry don't worry about them right bank
robbers are going against going up
against entire institutions they're
they're it's they're they're at war
against a system not necessarily an
individual
and uh
if they're doing no jobs and [__] the
feds know all about what a no job is you
know I mean like and the banks know what
a no job is yeah it's just that for
insurance purposes it's better just to
go along with it giving the money well
yeah because you never know I mean you
don't want the situation to go sideways
and then like you're comfortable all of
a sudden that money's insured they'll
get reimbursed that's what I mean so
it's just like it's not worth it getting
people and they will eventually catch
you I think most of the dudes they
eventually care that's what I mean see
it's like I I think about it sometimes
I'm like man it'd be really cool to like
you know the elevator would catch it but
yeah I'm just I'm not a MasterCard
you'll do about 10 15 years
it would be something it would be some
dumb [__] I forgot about and then I'd be
like that'll be working but if you did a
takeover robbery like something out of
the freaking heat and even if you didn't
kill anybody you're probably gonna do 40
50 years yeah yeah so you know
um
Oscar Perez says tying up and shooting a
seven-year-old and her mom's scumbag
yeah yeah I mean just [__] hell
cold-blooded I got a feeling that that
was his that was that was his first and
last one maybe I'm not really anything
or he might have gone to somebody's
house I don't think he killed that first
woman I think that was unrelated
yeah the cops are um they're like well
it could be related but they're thinking
maybe not but they do think that the
murder like the Nancy and Joey murder is
related to the other
they think it's the same dude that did
the other
um kidnapping yeah like where the the
woman on the yeah the Baby Lips it's the
same dude it's Gotta Be I mean that's
like I don't think the intent was to
kill any of the victims it was just
immobilize intimidate get their money
and go he thought it'd be easy to be
able to get do a bunch of them
man you can't get away with that long
for a long period of time something's
going to go wrong with that plan and you
got to do this on a regular basis to get
enough money to live off of
that's what I mean it's like 200 bucks
here 500 bucks catch up with you yeah
it's like [__] man that won't even that
won't even cover like a month not even a
month's worth of your rent that was that
won't even cover a week
of my bills no so yeah loves you talking
about not even a month worth of rent I
mean right
yeah like I said what's that like a
third a third of our rent no it's like
it's not even yeah it's like maybe a
quarter of the rent
well they asked what's his name I think
it was [__] you know George Nelson
you know why are you rob banks because
that's where the money is [__] yeah I
think it was shorts can't argue with
that yeah yeah why are you robbing why
are you rob banks because that's where
your money is yeah
yeah I mean
uh Camp guy said is his motive plain old
murder is he looking for money or
financial reward or a combination of
both money and then Mark says just
looking at the amounts if he wanted
money there's better ways money probably
secondary to the kidnapping or control
aspect yeah maybe he's kind of getting
off on it a little bit I think you're
giving him too much credit I think he's
dumb dumb and inexperienced well most of
them are done yeah I mean yeah I don't I
don't think he was into that I think he
thought this was a brilliant plan he
thought he thought he was a criminal
mastermind and that I kind of feel like
they all made yeah and that you know
he'd be able to do this forever you know
what I mean he'd be able to do this
regularly and [__] be a millionaire
in a few months he didn't do the math
you know he didn't figure the numbers I
think he's a real genius
yeah I'll just put goggles on their
faces I'll spray paint and black they'll
never they'll never know it was me
yeah well he got away
well that's what I mean it's like in
some ways it can't be that dumb yeah
killed two people for [__] 500 bucks
right one of them a seven-year-old girl
that's a failure
yeah for 500 bucks
500 million they're probably there are
people that would think of that their
disciples like oh yeah 500 million yeah
I can bring a little girl over here yeah
people would do a bunch of [__] up
[__] yeah 500 million 500 no
no that's [__] crazy
but they got crazy [__] that'll
shoot you over a [__] pair of
sneakers and [__]
that's what I mean people have been shot
over way less dumbass teenagers yeah
you know if everyone's not in their
right Minds yep and everyone's emotions
are all heightened and whatnot yep
um
Jeffy art says by the way guys not to be
one of those but it's usually pronounced
masoner Park which is interesting
because it occurred to me while I was
reading the notes that I was like I bet
I'm pronouncing this wrong even though
it looks like it's very obvious how you
would pronounce it because it's
basically like m-i-z-n-e-r and I was
just like why would you pronounce that a
different way but of course because
that's how we roll I guess uh and I'm
thoroughly convinced it is in fact
Steven Seagal yeah
allegedly it probably allegedly
allegedly don't say me Steven Seagal
yeah I don't and don't say it Steve is
gonna [__] call because I keep
hearing you keep talking about me on
your [__] show
don't think I'm not so fat that I'll
come out there
I'm still six foot two goddammit better
[__] respect me I'll [__] get up
I'll go I'll go all the way to Florida
from Russia I'll even bring Putin with
me I'll [__] you up that's what he's
saying the beginner right over here on
their unicorns yeah yeah I'll [__] you
up and I keep seeing that [__] shirt
you're wearing that flock of cigars I'm
gonna kick your ass for that
and stop talking about Kelly
yeah
they're not still married are they no
you still want people to talk about it
well why why is that any of his business
anymore don't you talk about my things
he's still got I still got a hold on
that
okay Steve
does he really think that best piece of
ass ever even better than a nation
experience
oh my God
ah Camp guy says Israel Keys robbed a
bunch of banks well as a matter of fact
uh Israel Keys is one of the suspects or
Persons of Interest I forgot which one
that was we're gonna talk about him in a
little bit okay
uh Jeff yard said by the way uh who is
it Milner or mitt I don't know if you're
talking about Mason or whatever has an
amazing ramen restaurant called Ramen
lab and a great bakery called Just Baked
sorry Local eats plug-in yeah that
sounds good
um Mark says I think taking the victim
to the ATM and making them get him money
is a control move too maybe I mean it
may be uh Zach said by the way the photo
you have on the thumbnail is both
gorgeous and creepy as [__] that is
actually a photograph of
um the of Nancy and Joey's vehicle that
was left in the parking lot
I don't know if they if they took the
picture like when it was but yeah that's
what the picture is let me try to get
them cam you're trying to get on camera
please you want to be on camera she's
like no no no no no no no I'm escaping
oh look at her face yeah she's like oh
my God what just happened what just
happened yeah before I poop what does it
matter
she's like oh she's been running around
making noises all night yeah why are you
talking who you talking about pay
attention yeah she's like I don't give a
[__] about the show
[__] look she's she's making a little
mad face yeah you won't go out you want
to get down you can get down she's like
[__] this she's she's not a lap Kitty
she likes to be on the floor she likes
you to come down on the floor
yeah dude but she doesn't like to be up
she doesn't like to get picked up and
stuff like that
so um so yeah
so sadly they did get like some DNA out
of the vehicle again it didn't match
anybody uh at least so far they don't
know
um where exactly Nancy and her daughter
were shot like if they were shot at the
mall or if they you know drove them
somewhere else and shot them and then
brought it back they also don't know
because I guess it was out of the range
of the cameras
um when their car was returned to the
parking lot like with the dead bodies in
it so you know they didn't find out any
of that stuff
so a couple days after this happened
um they actually put out uh put out in
the public they did like a reward of
four hundred thousand dollars
um because the FBI at this point had
come in and so basically they just went
full on into the investigation because
like I said it's like this is a mom and
her daughter for Christ's sake so
they're gonna get real um you know
they're gonna really want to get to the
bottom of this now
in the initial stages the investigation
they actually did Identify two Persons
of Interest for reasons which will
become clear in a minute
only a few days after the incident like
almost a week later I think it was
December 18th they um they found there
was this guy named David Goodman and
then they also had like um a drawing of
a dude that at that time they only knew
was named Charles and they released
those to the media as these are like
Persons of Interest so if you know
anything about them like come forward
with information
now this Charles person
um was later identified through a
witness as a guy named Charles Jackson
now the reason that they wanted him uh
for questioning was because there were
records like saying that he had Nancy's
cell phone
right
um and also the other guy David Goodman
had
um possession of Nancy's credit card
so that's kind of why they were
interested to talk to them
so after they released this information
to the media
um only actually I think it was only a
couple hours later they actually found
David Goodman uh they found him at in a
Miami Burger King of all places
so they didn't arrest him but they took
him into custody and like questioned him
and uh he they actually did arrest him
like but not for that like he had an
outstanding warrant said for some other
things so they were less arrested him
for that so they could keep him longer
and then the next day they found the
other guy Charles Jackson uh he was also
in Miami and they interviewed him as
well now basically what these two guys
said they don't think I don't think at
this point they think these two guys are
like The Killers but they essentially
um they stated that they found her cell
phone and her credit card
um just in like on First Avenue
Northeast First Avenue in Miami
and I guess like their story checked out
um because as far as I know they were
never like arrested for either crime but
they just thought they were like kind of
suspicious because they had some of her
stuff you know what I mean they found it
but they said they found it like just in
the street or I don't know if it was in
the street or dumpster or something
ditched it yeah that's kind of what
they're suspecting so but I guess these
two guys like you know they their
stories like uh checked out
so um so yeah so they're the cops are
down in Miami
you know uh passing Flyers out down
there because they think well you know
maybe since the stuff was dumped down
here like maybe this is where the Killer
is as well so basically that's as far as
I know like where the case is at the
moment
um I was watching there's a couple on
YouTube there's um like a couple updates
it seems like they do an update like
every year and they're just like this
many years since the case is not solved
and everything like that and a lot of
the cops in question are really um
you know because I guess it was because
it was a mom and a little girl I mean
they're taking it real personally so um
you got to be brought to Justice yeah so
a lot of them are like really like you
know head up to like uh you know to
solve it just a mom alone but come on 70
year old girl nah you gotta keep talking
to you and she's like cute as [__] too
you gotta go to jail bro I mean that's
he'd probably be watching this he's
probably watching this program you got
to go to jail well see that kind of like
freaks me out I was thinking about
anytime we do a show about a case that's
this recent I mean 2007 it's you know
sort of recent and they never caught the
person yeah then you know you always got
to kind of like worry that he's gonna
like turn up I think what it was ah nah
I think what he was was a a novice
criminal mastermind self-made criminal
mastermind
that he came up with this uh
sophisticated plan to uh make regular
money
uh by hijacking people and taking them
to the
to the uh ATM
not realizing that kidnapping alone
[__] carries a lot man in most
southern states like Louisiana and
Mississippi
kidnapping and that's just taking
someone somewhere where they do not want
to go is a life sentence well kidnapping
is the federal offense it's a life
sentence most of the year so you so this
whole thing you know grabbing your ex
grabbing your ex-girlfriend and throwing
in the car come on we're going that can
bring you life and most others yeah um
don't do that too yeah
um
so you have to if you're a professional
thief or a professional criminal you
have to weigh all these charges that are
going to be leveled against you just
kidnapping somebody
life or close to life
so you're like man you really want to
commit a crime where if you get caught
you do life that's even more than the
robbery
you know yeah
and then you say well you know if I get
caught as life so maybe I should just
kill these people
now you got that on your head
get out of it
so I'm saying this is a novice this is
somebody who doesn't really understand
the system probably never done any time
doesn't really know the law
a good professional criminal knows the
criminal law in and out they know all of
what could be leveled against them and
how much time they get for it what the
prosecutor you know what the pro
successful prosecutions what does it
take for that how much what evidence
that they need what can they get on a
plea bargain they know the whole [__]
system even know what prisons they're
going to go to Oh They'll probably send
me the Central Lockup I'll be there for
a couple years and then they'll send me
out to one of the other [__]
penitentiaries their Five-Year Plan yeah
oh you know marky's down there and I'll
probably be able to see you know Woody
wood you know we'll see him and yeah
I'll see [__] chain lightning with
we'll hang out
yeah that's that's his that's his that's
his that's his ex
[Laughter]
chain lighting you know just so they're
gonna have you know so are you high
right now no I should be though
I don't think he knew what he was doing
and uh on that one
with the little girl he lost control of
the damn situation he shot that girl he
shot that woman probably
with this little girl he shoots her
instead of letting her go he shoots her
right okay because he's scared of
getting caught
well if you're scared of getting caught
why are you committing this crime then
don't [__] do it yeah if you can't do
the time then don't do the crime
you know
the criminal life is a bunch of gambles
you know and uh he he wasn't ready
and I think this I think this [__] him
up actually if you ask me I don't think
he's a monster I just think he's dumb
or very unwise and I think that happened
I think that [__] him up I think he
retired
I mean it could go either way too
because like I said I'm pretty sure I'm
99 sure like I said I'm not a copper or
anything like that but 99 sure that this
is the same dude that did at least that
one other Abduction of the mom and the
two-year-old that was um you know that
they got let go and so I don't know if
like you said it does seem like because
Nancy's wrist you know the bonds on her
wrists were broken so it does seem like
she tried to escape or call the police
or something like that and he maybe just
freaked out or it could be that he you
know started out doing that kind of [__]
and then like a serial killer got braver
and braver and started like pushing it
farther but since there weren't any
other ones like at least in this area
like who knows what might have happened
he might have got killed or he might
have moved away or something like that
but we're trying to break loose and call
that could be one of two things
he was talking so much cash [__] that
she got scared and tried to bolt with
her life as one option
another thing is is that he was so soft
she didn't take him seriously
she thought he was full of [__]
you know he could have been that too
oh he's a [__] I'm getting out of here
[__] this I'm going I'm taking my
daughter with me God damn it go ahead
and shoot me he did shoot her might have
been something like that possibly
there's no there's
he said I'll do it I'll do it [__] I'll
do it you know but he might have been a
doofus you know what I mean it didn't
really come across as a strong
as a strong enough character to just
commit murder you know
so maybe she just didn't take him
seriously
yeah that could be because that could go
either way you got to put yourself you
have to have what's called uh strategic
empathy you have to be able to [__]
empathize with the Enemy what are they
feeling what are they thinking at the
time how is this going to go what would
happen if you'd tried to do this
and it could have been that she didn't
take him seriously
yeah maybe [__] you I'm getting out of
here you know it's that kind of [__]
I hate to say but that's probably what I
would do like my mouth would get me
injured yeah
he's just trying to do because I would
just say some kind of sarcastic yeah
he's trying to do his second or third
little shot in the face transaction and
then [__] she puts him in the corner
she Corners him and [__] he he shoots
her and then the little kid starts
screaming and he's oh [__] he shoots her
I mean
that's [__] up he should have done it
well yeah that's obviously that's a
[__] ass crime
yeah it's a [__] ass crime to begin
with taking people to the ATM
that's some [__] a crackhead does
there's not enough money there
and like I said even if well if I think
about it you I mean seriously somebody
abducts me and takes me to ATM I'm like
jokes on you [__] there's not
any money in there yeah you can maximum
500 but like 500 I don't have 500 that's
crackhead money 500 bucks I was like I
don't even have fish you know like that
yeah
ill the most you're gonna get is 500
bucks so that's that's crackhead money
that's not enough money to [__]
kill somebody over or [__] jeopardize
your freedom as a free man you know I
don't give a [__] how if you're that
[__] desperate go for where the money
is
don't go to the [__] so maybe like
you said maybe it is a crackhead I mean
I don't know though I get the feeling
that he's not because because there's a
lot of planning involved in this like I
said he's got the zip ties he's got the
dust tape he's got his goggles yeah yeah
he's an idiot criminal Master he's an
idiot clearly but he thinks he seems to
think that he's smart and he like has
all of this [__] planned out but like I
said it's kind of interesting that you
would think that if you
just needed money and just you know
we're like I'm gonna kidnap people and
take him to the ATM or whatever you
wouldn't go through all that rigmarole
of like binding them up because he did
that to the mom and son too and he
didn't kill them yeah so why would you
go through all that trouble unless you
had some other motivation no you're
reading into Mission there's people
saying it was a power and control thing
no if it was a power control thing he'd
raped him all right and it had been more
about that that's not what he was doing
he thought he was being real smart you
know they'll never catch me that kind of
stuff I'm a professional
but look at how low he's aimed his
sights
he he's willing to [__]
jeopardize his freedom and jeopardize
the lives of [__] innocent civilians
over 500 bucks
but he thinks he's real smart he's got
this thing all planned out with the
goggles and this and that
no man you couldn't [__] throw the
gun down
and just walk into a bank with a note
having the money or I'll start opening
fire on these people
and they'll give you a lot more money
and when you get caught you'll do a lot
less time
and the thing is if you're so desperate
you need that much money
that prison time is your [__]
retirement plan you don't have to worry
about paying bills when you go in there
yeah you just like they'll feed you give
you a place yeah yeah if you [__] get
housing [__] uh to show you movies uh
uh you know if I could you can go out on
a yard you can do all kinds of [__] you
know so you know you've been there for
about 10 15 years you don't have to
worry about paying your rent
[Laughter]
almost sounds nice
well well it's like those art thieves
yeah they steal the [__]
piece of art and then they go to the
cops saying I think I know where your
piece of art is if you give me the money
I'll go get it back for you they arrest
him then he sits in [__] jail for
[__] four or five years goes I don't
know where it is but if you let me go
and you give me the money
I'll find that [__] Rembrandt for you
and that dude he did that many times
somebody's in there for two years
eventually they crack and go okay
then let the guy go and give him the
money and then
magically the painting [__]
reappears let's do a show about that guy
yeah yeah and he was holding it hostage
the whole time with hit a whole bunch of
accomplices out there and him going to
to prison was
part of the plan yeah he had it all
mapped out he had it all but him because
he was going to do a couple years in
prison which I respect that yeah he
didn't he didn't hurt anybody he never
heard anybody stealing [__] yeah but he
was going to go to prison
for a couple years and get out and get
two or three million dollars
right
which that like I said that all that's
how much money is that a day that sounds
pretty reasonable yeah so yeah you're
getting paid you're right he had it all
he had an office right and he and like
he said he was willing to go to prison
he knew he was gonna go yeah and he
would be like you guys have held me here
for two two years
if I did anything wrong maybe I paid for
it I haven't done anything wrong if you
let me go
um and you give me the money I'm pretty
sure I could get that painting for you I
think I know who has it
yeah yeah
he kind of has he's just holding it for
hostage and that thing's a National
Treasure they have to have it back yeah
and that's why he's doing it yeah and
he's not set he didn't steal
a [__] Bob Ross [__] no he stole a
[__] Rembrandt okay because he knew
that that's real leverage yeah that's
going for the big bucks you know it's
real leverage I mean Bob Ross I [__] Bob
Ross if I could he had a whole bunch of
Pepe
Rembrandt died centuries ago he's never
painting anything yeah that's right
unless somebody clones is that damn
Priceless painting it's a national
[__] treasure I still I still want to
do a show about the Isabella Gardner
Museum Heist as well because I don't
think they ever got those paintings back
they're still gone yeah and that was a
long time ago that happened
um Jeff erart said anyone that hurts a
little kid babies or animals is a
special kind of evil and a coward to
boot yeah
big time or an idiot
well that those aren't mutually
exclusive
if you're it said what if it was some
bored Boca brat yeah yes that's a term
some kid or guy from a local high income
background who went in too many internet
chat rooms
you know that might be a possibility
maybe it's somebody that's not like a
quote-unquote career criminal or
something like that maybe it was
somebody just
pretending or doing it for kicks yeah
that kind of seems more
in line with what we're saying you know
what I mean like he really didn't need
the money right
that's what I mean maybe that's not
exactly what the motivation was Mark
said he's a loser with a one-inch dick
probably yeah I mean that pretty much
goes without saying
but yeah so this case in particular
um this this double murder uh has been
on America's Most Wanted three times
um as of this episode maybe actually
maybe more at this time but I think it's
been on there at least three times and
um yeah they've done the sketch like I
said it's not a great sketch the dude
had sunglasses and and a hat on so they
didn't really get a good look at him
because like I said they think this was
the same dude that kidnapped the um the
woman and her son from them from the
same Mall uh they don't actually
have any physical or forensic evidence
that relates uh this case to the other
ones but and they definitely think that
the Randy gorenberg one the first one
that happened in uh March they think
that was somebody else you know what I
mean like because the Emma was not
exactly the same even though it happened
like in the same area
um now one Theory somebody brought this
guy up earlier that has been circulating
about the Boca murders or are they
called like the Boca killer I've seen
them called as well
um is that perhaps
at least the murders of Nancy and Joey
were perpetrated by serial killer Israel
Keys now we actually did a show about
Israel keys I think it was episode 99
which was probably like four years ago
now he was um as someone mentioned he
was a serial killer and a bank robber
which you don't usually see those two
things together uh but he was also did
kidnapping burglar arson uh and also a
sex offender because he was just ticking
all the boxes I guess he was a real
[__] Dirtbag he's dead now thankfully
um now they know that he murdered at
least three people
um and he did like a [__] ton of other
crimes like I said he was an arsonist he
did armed robberies he did rapes uh you
know just burglaries [__] like that
um this was from 2001 to 2012. that was
like before they caught him
now while he was in jail awaiting trial
Israel Keys committed suicide because
again coward got caught and then he
committed suicide
um he hanged himself and slashed his
wrist both like you know just making
sure I guess
now they found in his jail cell he left
like a suicide note and in this suicide
note he had drawn
11 skulls and like a Baphomet and I
don't know he was like that's so Edge
lordy
um and some kind of like weird
inscriptions that he had like written on
the wall
and because of the stuff that he wrote
in his suicide note the FBI thought that
maybe the 11 was a reference to how many
people he actually had killed because
they convicted him or they you know they
know that he killed at least three but
they suspect that he killed more people
than that
um and they think that his crimes go all
the way back to 1996. uh he like raped a
teenage girl in or in Oregon now as I
said he is still as far as I know a
suspect in these Boca Raton not the
Randy gorenberg one necessarily but um
the murders of Nancy and Joey the mom
and the daughter because
it's kind of similar to his MO
and also the sketch it's sort of kind of
looks like him because like the
description of that the mother gave the
one that was abducted with her son and
you know survived
Sheik described him she said he had a
mask and sunglasses on but she did see
like a glimpse of his face she said he
was tall he was athletically built and
had a kind of long hair and sort of
looked like Israel I think like the
pictures that I've seen of Israel keys
he had short hair but I think for a time
like he did have like long hair so it
kind of like matched his description at
the time so some people have speculated
that maybe it was him because it was
kind of similar he had like the whole
little tool kit thing and all that kind
of crap like serial killers do
so some people have thought that maybe
that maybe he was the one that did that
because they think that he did more
crimes than he got
um than he got blamed for but like I
said they don't think that the same
person that shot Randy gorenberg in
March and pushed her out her car they
don't think that's necessarily the same
person as the person that killed seems
like a difference Joey yeah that's what
I mean because I think as far as I know
like the Randy gorenberg one I don't
even know like if they stole her money
or took her to an ATM or anything like
that I think they just like put her in
um
put her in her car and then like shot
her and pushed her out which to me seems
more like they were thinking that one
was more like either something to do
with like her family which is why they
were interested in like investigating
like her husband and her son and her
son's Associates and stuff they either
thought it was that or that it was like
a gang thing like a gang initiation type
[__] might have just been more like a
carjacking than gone wrong
yeah it could have been that too if they
wanted that SUV right because it was new
I think yeah it was a Mercedes and uh
she put up too much of a fight they shot
her and then they go okay we gotta ditch
the car it's too hot now
yeah maybe that's what maybe it was just
that yeah because there's a murder
associated with it so we got to get rid
of the vehicle and then the white
vehicle you said that they thought might
have been associated with and they
picked the dude up after they ditched
the card and goes yeah [__] this one
we'll go get another one
Camp guy said uh Israel Keys wasn't
under rent cars and drive long distances
I wonder if they have car rental records
for him during this time period yeah I'd
be interested to know that too because
it does seem like
I don't know you could get away with a
lot more [__] like back in the 70s and
80s during the serial killer Heyday or
whatever like nowadays it's really hard
to rent a car or you know stay at a
hotel or anything like that like without
unless you got like really really good
fake IDs and everything is I don't think
there's as many offenders anymore either
I don't think there's as many serial
killers as they're using no I mean
there's still some wandering around
there always are but um I don't think
there's many of us are used it really
doesn't seem well I kind of feel like
crime in general has been declining
since the 90s but you know there's
spikes here and there but it's not the
way it used to be I think people really
forget like how
how high the crime was like in the 70s
and 80s yeah the the [__] 70s were
[__] violent as [__] they were yeah
yeah people people don't realize it they
were it's a it's a lot better yeah 80s a
little bit too I think and you know
my hypothesis was uh leaded gasoline
and like I said you're not the only
person that says that I don't think
that's the entire thing but um I mean
there's probably like a lot of other
factors but I mean that sounds like a
pretty solid let it guess
it's all kind of crazy [__]
running around back then somebody
thought it was a good idea to put lead
inside a gasoline and that after it
blows out the engine pipe when it's not
LED anymore
no it's LED it's blowing around
everywhere and people are breathing it
in as young kids remember when I was a
kid
in California
you could see the smog and my eyes would
be water and I'd be coughing and adults
would look at me like what's wrong with
the kid and I said and and people go I
think it's the smog adults didn't
weren't uh susceptible to it but little
kids it was like you're smoking later on
as a smoker I realized what it was like
you've been smoking yeah your eyes had
burned you'd breathe yeah that was
another reason pollution back then
pollution
and there was lead in that [__] and
that'll make you violent and crazy
and uh you know it wouldn't be to the
same concentration in everybody
and uh some people would get worse
exposure than others and it might tip a
a violent [__] over the edge and
make him even worse you know just
same thing was happening to the Romans
evidently drinking out of lead pipes and
eating off a lead silverware or lead
plates
that's what I'm saying because if we
talk about this a lot when we talk about
you know serial killers is that usually
it has to be kind of like a conflation
of factors I definitely do think that
some people are born like with a
proclivity toward that kind of thing and
if they if there are other environmental
factors like they get abused as children
or like you said you know they grew up
in the 60s or 70s and breathed in lead
fumes all the time
um and they already had that proclivity
towards violence or whatever yeah that's
that's just like a [__] perfect storm
of [__] yeah you could get exposed to it
and then once you're away from the lead
Cloud around big cities eventually you'd
work it out of your system but it takes
a long time to work on things like lead
and Mercury out of your system
yeah I I mean I definitely think I I
really want to look more into that
because I'm like I said you're not the
only person that I've heard like I've
heard like other scientists and stuff
like that talking about that being maybe
being a factor because people have
noticed that like yeah the crime used to
be like really really horrible like back
in the [__] 60s and 70s yeah mostly
the 70s I feel like well I think feel
like the serial killer I end up with you
know people talk a lot about the 70s I
think the the peak of the serial killer
thing was
87 it's either 87 or 89 that was like
the peak year but then like after that
it started like precipitously declining
mid 70s the late 70s it seemed to be
like in mid 70s maybe like early 80s
a lot of violence towards women yeah
it just sounds like lead
lead poisoning
you know yeah mix their mixing [__]
sex and violence together just like
uncalled for [__] just abducting [__]
random women and sticking ice picks
through their ears like the toolbox
murderers yeah that was 70s I think
wouldn't it yeah yeah what did we need
to show about them well because I get
confused because there's two different
yeah there's two different cases that
are called toolbox yeah you know murders
or whatever basically dealing with
[__] mutants yeah they were probably
born under those conditions too
[__] just born in a cloud of [__]
toxic [__] waste yeah and it went way
back because you look at Albert Fish he
was doing crazy [__] during during the
[__] Industrial Revolution some of
these some of these uh cities
during the Industrial Revolution were
[__] polluted yeah it polluted Beyond
Your Wildest imagination
[__] Mercury and Lead was everywhere
uh Mercury especially because they were
using it to tan hides and do things in a
leather industry and they didn't give a
[__] they're drinking the water that
they had [__] pissing in they're just
[__] crazy
and uh there's no
accurate crime statistics from those
eras like say in 1800s New York's people
just knew that it was like hell on Earth
you know yeah well because Oracle points
out yeah many crimes historically went
under underreported yeah yeah and
especially back then I kind of feel like
really they didn't have
[__] even until the 70s they didn't
really have like a nationwide Network
where you could kind of like catch a
dude if they went to another state or
something like that they wouldn't have
that there were no cops as you would
recognize them until I think the 20s
20s was when and you really the police
of the 20s weren't were more kind of
like Mall security
yeah they were they were
and before before the police they didn't
really have them people just carried
guns
and um you had sheriffs and [__] if they
needed to catch somebody they'd just get
up on a bunch of citizens together who
were able-bodied and had horses and they
deputize them and make them into a posse
we're going to catch these guys
the closest thing to
anything that you would call
organized
policing and detective and forensics
work would have been like the pinkertons
that was 1800s they were Private
Security Agency
matter of fact they they were they
protected the president they were
basically the Secret Service for a long
time the pinkertons
and the pinkertons did bad [__] if
you're [__]
I wonder if you're sure about that we
need to do yeah they recruited from
there was ever [__] Boba Fett's
really they would recruit people right
out of prison if they had certain
talents they would just hire anybody
um as long as they could get the job
done
including women you use a lot of sex
operatives and [__]
and uh you know but if your factory was
getting ready to have was having a
Revolt you could call the pinkertons and
they'd show up the [__] guns and
machine guns and shoot into the crowd
and [__] disperse [__] riots by
force and that [__] was just totally
good to go in in Old America
they just did whatever they wanted if
you had money the issue would fly
Oracle says Tom don't forget about white
lead being used in makeup from the Roman
Empire up through at least the
Elizabethan era yeah I mean well the
Romans also seasoned food with powdered
lead I mean the [__] that was in
people's houses too like if you read I
read this really great book like a few
years ago I can't remember the name of
it but they were talking about like just
all the poisonous [__] like especially
like up until the Victorian area like a
little bit after just people like even
your everything in your house like your
wallpaper curtains everything like that
was just toxic lead-based paint yeah
everything was like the dyes that they
used like for it was just like
unbelievable and it's just known these
are mind-altering substances that make
you [__] mean as [__]
yeah
uh James Knapp says violent crime peaked
in 1991 and dropped every year until
2016. yeah I knew it was some time I for
some reason I thought it was 1989 but
yeah so I was kind of close what they're
talking about in 91 was like that sounds
like the peak of the crack epidemic
yeah that's probably what you're talking
about
yeah I'm trying to remember I guess that
was it right around then wasn't it yeah
it started to die down after that though
yeah
I mean I remember I mean I was a little
kid in the 70s but I definitely do
remember it being
but it's weird because it I remember it
being like or people perceived that it
was a lot more dangerous but then like
parents and stuff like that were a lot
more relaxed too there was no internet
yeah that's true they were just like
yeah go out and play come back later
when it started it was mostly safe
though yeah better know where you lived
but it was mostly safe yeah I didn't
really have too much trouble like when
people forget how big the United States
is
yeah I mean it's
I guess it's not like not any
consolation if like something bad does
happen to you because it can't happen
but
um you know for the point of view of an
American if you're not in America
yeah all these crimes happening but
they're always happening somewhere else
yeah I mean usually they're usually
somewhere else and they're not happening
to you
it's just it's [__] big there's a lot
of people here
and the thing about it too is that
I think people have a perception that
there's more crime that there than there
is because you hear about it so much but
the reason you hear about it is because
one everybody wants to hear about it
because that's just how humans are we
like to hear about that kind of like
morbid [__] but also because it's
unusual
if it happened all the time they
wouldn't even bother reporting it you
know what I'm saying so the fact that
there's a lot of crimes they don't ever
bother report anymore well yeah but
that's been going on forever though yeah
Jeff here it says uh I also think serial
killers will now change their ammo in
order to throw off the authorities and
the thing about it is that I'm sure
there's still serial killers running
around I mean the Long Island serial
killer is probably still out there and
there's some other ones as well but
they're made the same way it well yeah
it seems like well the whole culture is
like not really the same and the thing
about it too is that
as much as you know the the csiing of of
society like everybody knows so much
more about forensic science and
investigation and everything like that
now including serial killers so maybe
they
but like I said I've changed their
methods like to make it harder for them
to get caught because the thing about it
is that like all the serial killers that
were idiots all got caught like the ones
that there's still ones out there but
they're obviously not getting caught
serial killers are a are are a basically
a [__] what do you call it a sexual
identity it's like a um
that's their orientation
murder and sex drives have been kind of
put together in the same thing and I
don't think there's many of them as
there used to be and I don't really
think they're produced this by the same
methods I don't think they're they're
made the same anymore
um because the world's changed a lot I
think uh internet and social media have
diffused a lot of the problems that
caused serial killers to be created
because I think you kind of have to have
isolated males who are [__] up
getting lost within a world of their own
fantasies
with without with like uh without any
sexual Outlets
well in minimal interaction with other
people that have like similarities so
they end up [__] being like Jeffrey
Dahmer if you look at Jeffrey Dahmer he
just kind of [__] devolved into his
own [__] inner world of [__]
perverse Insanity you know [__]
necrophilia and
didn't want to be by he didn't want to
be alone you know well the internet
would probably would have [__] been a
good price pressure release valve on a
guy like that
he probably would have thought about it
he probably never would have done it
see I kind of wonder about that because
I know that some and you know I don't
know the statistics on this because I
know that there are some like maybe on
the other side that have the perception
of you know oh it's just like
encouraging like bad behavior because
it's like you know if somebody that has
like all these [__] up fantasies or
something can find other people with
that and they like yeah and they kind of
like friends and they and they're kind
of like um you know maybe talking each
other into like grade which I guess that
can happen too but I don't know I kind
of feel like
I think they end up like the Vore
community
yeah where they talk about it they don't
ever do it
except for the Wonders here but but the
thing about it is that like they would
probably have done it anyway like even
if they didn't
the I mean the most extreme are gonna
like do the [__] okay I think of Jeffrey
Dahmer to be born again in the modern
era I don't think he would have ever
developed it into this see I yeah I kind
of agree Matthews aren't there anymore
it's not the same it's not the same and
see I'm like I'm always I know you can't
like ever run that experiment but I'd
always be interested to run that
experiment like some serial killers I
just think were just like born monsters
and like they probably would have they
might not have committed the same exact
crimes in the same exact way but they
still would have been horrible people
Dahmer and gay see their their main
problems their main problem was is that
they were gay
and they felt that they wouldn't be
accepted in a time when it wasn't really
accepted they weren't be they wasn't
acceptable so they had to hide it all
right and then the hiding part of it
[__] ended up murder ended up being
part of hiding it and also power plays
especially like with Gacy Gacy was
nowadays if gay should be born again
he'd just been a leather daddy
he'd be down with the [__] fetish
kill him
yeah it's like probably no one would say
boo I'm like
I mean like I said it's hard to say
because we can't run Casey just wanted
to type young boys have sex with them
and beat them up and then call them
sissies
you know that's BDSM yeah which like I
said you can he could have found a guy
who wanted to be right you can find like
consensuals yeah and he'd go to a damn
Club [__] waves everybody else while
he's doing it and he can dress up as a
[__] clown you know it it did so it
never made me like the [__] that he
thought was taboo wasn't as taboo as he
thought it was it didn't drive him to
the [__] levels of perversion and
murder that it did
holding the secrets always makes it
worse
and that was the whole thing you know if
I can with with Gacy and Dahmer is that
they were trying to keep everything a
secret it just got worse and worse and
worse and uh and always trying to like
yeah I always kind of feel like the
problem is you're trying to project a an
image that isn't true that isn't you
um you know for acceptability and that's
that never ends well yeah and then the
straight dudes that are killing there's
similar type similar I think with them
though just what it boils down to is
rejection they can't do with rejection
yeah that's a big part of it yeah well
if you look at [__] the Green River
Killer what was his name
Gary Ridgewood Ridgeway yeah I mean
they're not much of a man there I mean
he's just [__]
pitiful right
he was married but it wasn't good enough
for him he he he wanted more women he he
wanted access to a lot of women
but the problem was is he didn't want
the woman there
he wanted the woman's dead body because
he didn't want anybody looking at him
yeah basically he just wanted to
masturbate with a woman's body
which like I said I'm like dude they
have sex dolls
well he he'd go back you know when they
were rotten and he would have sex with
him
so he had [__] serious issues
yeah you could say that you're right
yeah he had serious [__] issues but
it was fear of rejection he didn't want
women looking at him disapprovingly so
the best thing to do in his mind was to
kill these women
and then you'd have total control over
them and they couldn't look at him right
so he could he could be comfortable
yeah that's what it was
yeah and like I said when you put it
that way it seems like really obvious
yeah and I think like a lot of
especially ones that have like that
necrophile type yeah because when
they're there they can disapprove of you
right when they're not like they're not
doing it right yeah when they're when
they're not there then it doesn't matter
really weird like a lot a lot of evil is
coming out of the world because dudes
were afraid that like a chick would
laugh at them yeah yeah yeah crazy yeah
it's like it's really not that big a
deal just calm down
um but yeah so as I said these murder
cases are still open so obviously if you
know if anybody knows anything about
them uh to please contact the Palm Beach
County Police Department uh there were
also on the Wikipedia page for the Boca
Town Center Mall
they also noted uh some other more
recent incidents now this one uh
thankfully this one ended up with no one
hurt and it's like actually kind of
funny but this happened in October of
2019 and apparently there were like all
these like quick popping sounds and
everybody thought it was like an active
shooter situation you know what I mean
like so everybody was like freaking out
um you know everybody in the mall did it
was just like a huge panic and then the
SWAT teams had to come and they did like
you know grid search through them all
everything like that just evacuated
everybody all that other kind of stuff
so they cleared them all out and then
they discovered that the popping noise
had actually come from a janitor who had
found a balloon in the food court and
popped it like on his cart like or like
a couple of balloons and just like pop
them and everybody like freaked the [__]
out they said the only person that was
injured was somebody that you know
during the Panic like tripped and fell
and like hurt themselves when they fell
on the floor but I was like well that's
good that like nobody was hurt but that
was just kind of funny
uh however in April of 2022 there was an
actual shooting there
um no one was killed thankfully again uh
but one person was shot in the leg
um but uh they just basically had to
lock down the mall
and uh [__] like that but um apparently
I don't really know what happened with
that all the Wikipedia page says is an
active shooter threat was quickly
dismissed and the incident was
categorized as isolated yeah just
isolated so I don't know if somebody
just walked in it was like like shot up
and then left or I don't know or they
shot somebody in the leg and then left I
was like that's a weird thing to say
that is pretty crazy but yeah so that
was like the most recent thing that
happened there but this poor Mall man
although I kind of feel like most malls
had bad ships that's what I was gonna
say what was the one I can't remember
the one that um Dan Bell talked about
one which was like I don't know if it's
still a shot is this girlfriend why she
was working yeah that's right yeah and
actually one of them like a cleaning
lady got like yeah murdered too I think
like somebody was trying to like steal
her purse or something and she fought
back and the dude shot her yeah and then
the cop came in and cop shot him
yeah yeah that's right yeah
I thought I remembered like wasn't was
this the same incident where somebody
just came in like in the department
store and they just like stole some lame
ass like a pair of jeans or some [__]
yeah that's right down to a shootout and
then they get a shootout over a pair of
[__] jeans I'm like really do you do
you think that bad dude wasn't thinking
straight he really wanted those jeans I
guess I mean he wouldn't have done
[__] 24 hours in jail for stealing
that's what I mean mean Jesus Christ
settle down
you had to give him court summons and
he'd go to court community service holy
crap ISO like when I worked in a mall I
worked in a um like a record store
and I love that like they always like
told us it's like oh if you see somebody
like stealing some [__] you go over
there and confront them I'm like I am
absolutely not doing that you can [__]
yourself right now but um we had
somebody steal how many CDs did they say
it was a bunch
um they were just like putting them like
underneath their you know shirts and
down their pants and everything like
that and I guess like the manager sort
of saw them and sort of like chased them
out of the store and for some reason
they went out of the store and then
tried to bury all of them in the planter
like that was like right outside the
store I'm like okay I was like what the
[__] was that all about the cops are
coming
you stash of the [__] like kind of
trying to bury him under the mulch or
whatever I'm just like okay whatever
[__]
but we did catch one guy he was like a
uh he was kind of like a teenager do you
look like kind of an upper middle class
teenage boy or whatever it looked like
he was just probably stealing just to be
cool or whatever but uh any money he got
he got caught and he got like pulled
into the back and the manager was like
reaming him a new [__] he was crying
it was pretty funny
yeah he did well she did take it out of
your ass yeah she was she was a little
she was a little fat lady okay and she
was just like man she was reading him
the riot act like said he was crying and
everything I went back there to like get
my stuff and I was like hey is that it
on this case uh yes it is okay yes it is
he's going to shut it down now
um
Jeffy art said never realized I was
risking my life just for The Container
Store yeah The Container Store is in the
small I've actually never been in a
container store is it what it sounds
like is it like you just go in there and
they have all different kinds of like
container like Tupperware and [__] like
that because that sounds kind of neat
but you know you don't bulk
oh my goodness hi there she's like
trying to come up on a chair
um but yeah all right so I guess we will
we've been on for two hours uh more or
less and you know I got work tomorrow so
I gotta get ready for bed and all that
kind of stuff so thank you everybody for
dropping by this evening and thank you
for whoever recommended this topic
because I probably wouldn't have got to
it if you hadn't recommended it even
though it's in Florida I had never heard
about it
um so yeah
we will be back on Friday night for our
Side Tracks show having some drinks and
like you know easing you guys into the
weekend as we do uh so yeah hopefully
you guys can come by and hang out with
us on Friday night thank you very much
for coming by tonight thank you for
super chats and all of that other stuff
and we will see you again on Friday
evening good night